ça commence bien salut salut Laurent
bonjour à tous
j'ai pas vérifié mais la caméra
qui franchement je peux pas quand tu es
comme ça c'est quand même c'est les
vacances tu vois parce que quand c'est
quand même une sacrée galère il faut il
faut tout mettre en place là tu vois on
a oublié de mettre le problème
ma petite caméra ma petite caméra est
grésée mais moi je te dis je me voyais
pas sur discord non non
c'est bon oui je sais que tu me voyais
tout à l'heure ah ben tu me vois plus
marcher bien l'entraînement comme ça et
là je te vois plus
attends non en fait je te vois pas
on a un bug on a tout marché bien juste
avant avant de lancer et puis là tout
d'un coup on ne voit plus Laurent
qui avait réduit alors voilà bonjour à
tous et désolé pour pour ces petits
problèmes de technique salut Laurent
salut à tous
bienvenue pour ce match
entre les trois chaînes Bulldogs et
les
Bishop arts
et du coup on a un match très important
aujourd'hui Laurent parce que du coup il
y a une calife à la clé donc l'équipe
qui va remporter ce match sera qualifié
du coup pour les pour les quarts de
finale
simplement c'est un weekend de finale ou
l'équipe perdante est éliminée l'équipe
gagnante passe en quart de finale et
donc dans cette
dans cette phase où voilà ça sera les 8
meilleures équipes qui vont se
rencontrer donc là c'est un huitième de
finale même s'il y a pas en fait
d'habitude c'est vrai qu'on est habitué
dans les compétition sportive alors
8e de finale mais là c'est pas du tout
comme ça
c'est simplement quelques-uns je crois
qu'il y en a combien il y a trop 4 c'est
ça parce que les autres équipes soient
temps éliminés soit soit qualifiés
évidemment on verra ensuite l'équipe de
l'équipe française équipe de bitstream
qui sera occupé qui sera opposés pardon
au chessbra de Magnus Carlson sans
manuscaren je me suis trompé j'ai mal
twitté j'ai vu mais pourquoi les chaises
sur Twitter ils annonçait manuscritson
il y a eu il y a eu un truc là ce qui
s'est passé je sais pas donc apparemment
remplacer des avantagesusement par anis
Giri
bon c'est quand même
c'est pas
une une féminine Jennifer you assez
forte évidemment et un joueur à 2004 un
peu un peu la même
alors un peu la même stratégie que
finalement l'équipe de [__] avec une
très forte joueuse Katia lagno deux
joueurs de premier plan Alexandre
ricchuk et Maxime Vacher La Grave et
ensuite
Maël Boyer un jeune un jeune plein
d'avenir
donc ça va être ça va être très sympa à
suivre évidemment vous pouvez suivre ça
après ce stream sur la chaîne
blindstream il va falloir que quelque
chose joue un peu mieux je vais me
moquer un petit peu mais j'ai battu
gritchouc au playing donc en 10 + 2 je
crois que c'est la cadence à 10 + 2 donc
va falloir qu'il y a quand même qui
muscle son jeu notre ami
notre ami
à Sacha gritchouc et ça a commencé déjà
commencer ça commence donc là du coup
l'orange je vais te laisser commencer à
faire tout ça enfin commenter un petit
peu ça dérange pas pendant que je vais
m'appeler les caméras donc on voit on
voit cheval au vin contre donc cheval au
Val à joueuse
la joueuse donc russe qui est l'idole la
nouvelle idole la nouvelle égérie de
Stéphane qui a adoré son style je lui
avais dit qu'elle a envoyé je pouvais le
voir et il a pas été déçu et donc elle
joue évidemment quand celui qu'on ne
présente plus la star de cette équipe
clairement avec Fabiano carronnaz
Benjamin BOC Nicolas théodoro et Alice
Lee c'est la star des Fabiano caroana
ancien numéro de mondial ancien
challengeur au titre mondial il a perdu
d'autres cheveux contre Magnus capsule
en 2018 il était à deux points et l'eau
de Magnus Carcès donc c'est le seul qui
a vraiment challengé manuscarsen sur ces
10 dernières années il y a une période
un peu moins bien ces derniers temps
mais quand même ça reste une une force
considérable et on voit
on voit que il joue un gambidam là face
à cheval voilà c'est vraiment c'est le
garmidane qu'on apprend à l'école où on
joue on met un pion aussi en main 7 on
rock on sent le cavalier on joue un
petit coup de C6 bon il joue un peu de
tout Fabi c'est avec le Gambie avec
elle-même une de ses ouvertures préférée
je pense que ça il sait aussi il a dû se
préparer il a dû la prendre au sérieux
cet adversaire et donc il s'est dit elle
joue elle joue dynamique elle aime bien
jouer actif on va jouer un truc de
solide pas besoin de de faire des folies
dans cette première partie parce que de
toute façon je suis valova c'est pas
genre à essayer de faire nul normalement
elle envoie ce qu'il faut donc voilà un
petit coup de de A6 là voilà on met tous
ces tous les petits pions sur blanc un
moment on va on va prendre sur ces
quatre certainement et jouer B5
très très classique
de la part de de Fabiano
caroanna on va voir ce que ça va donner
Fabiano Carona qui a joué le playing qui
a joué non qui a pas jouer le pays qui
était déjà qualifié qui avait gagné la
deuxième division dans le champion de
chez tour qui a lieu évidemment sur
chetcom et le prochain tournoi aura lieu
début avril j'ai tenté de me qualifier
j'ai malheureusement pas réussi mais
c'était une première expérience très
très sympa avec ses parties rapides
c'est la première fois que je vois
rapide sur internet en toi quand
Stéphane je te déconcentre pas mais
quand même première fois que je joue à
rapide alors je joue tout le temps des
blistes d'habitude et donc et du coup
l'expérience de jeu était sympa alors le
résultat à 50% pas terrible j'ai raté
plein de chance mais bon 50% j'aurais pu
j'avais un mauvais départage mais alors
le départage dans ces tournois c'est un
peu n'importe quoi parce que des joueurs
qui arrêtent de tournoi mais voilà avec
le départage j'aurais pu être dans les
dans les 70 premiers et jouer
et jouer une calife pour la troisième
division ce qui est ce qui est à peu
près mon niveau je pense donc voilà on
verra on a rejoint on a rejoint ça c'est
sûr parce que c'était c'était ça permet
de jouer des super joueurs et donc
c'était une belle initiative de de
chaise comme et du groupe du groupe
chascom play Magnus évidemment ce
tournoi qui avait lieu avant sur chaise
24 qui a maintenant changé de format
changer un peu de visage quitter agrandi
et je crois qu'ils sont pas ce que
j'aime beaucoup c'est aussi ce cette
remise en question permanente avec cette
tentative de d'amélioration on essaye
des choses et ma foi c'est comme les
joueurs d'échec pour accepter de se
tromper de temps en temps pour pour
s'améliorer sinon on progresse pas
donc voilà bon on va voir chubalova donc
toujours ici face à Fabi qui a pris un
peu de temps qui a joué cavalu le 4
intéressants comme d'habitude je suis
valova il nous fait des choses
intéressantes c'est 4 c'est très logique
de la part de famille créer un
déséquilibre surtout bien il va ensuite
jouer son fou sur la grande diagonale le
fou de casse blanche qui n'est pas
encore sorti il va développer sur B7 ça
joue cette position c'est à peu près
équilibré il joue assez vite très
pratique il a beaucoup d'entraînements
online ça joue aussi beaucoup c'est très
important cet entraînement en rapide et
Blitz où on développe des
et bien tout simplement des réflexes
voilà
ça c'est primordial on aura on peut
aller voir une autre partie enfin je te
dérange trop Benjamin Bocq peut-être
contre bardilly à Danette Var donc ouais
c'est quoi Sean Bulldogs qu'on connaît
moins bien mais bon on va les présenter
aussi quand même je trouve valova danesh
war un jeune ami indien normalement ça
sent le bon joueur quand même on a une
chic qui a
2-0 à Maxime va chez Lagrave rendez-vous
compte personnel j'ai dit à Maxime après
je l'ai vu j'ai vu deux trois jours plus
tard Maxime j'ai dit ben écoute désolé
genre allez parce que vous avez
l'impression que je critiquer mais en
fait pas du tout personne n'avait vu
venir enfin moi j'avais pas vu venir ce
2-0 contre une chic
Maxime non plus
je crois que personne n'avait vu venir
même une teach a dû être surpris donc
2-0 face à une réelle donc ça dit ça dit
beaucoup sur son niveau et on a ensuite
le numéro de cette équipe qui est Bogdan
des hack donc le jeune joueur roumain
plein de talents donc deux équipes je
dirais
sur le papier c'est quand même très très
équilibré avec peut-être un avantage
c'est ce que tu me disais avant le
stream au croissant bouledogs parce que
évidemment leur joueuse est quand même
au-dessus largement de Alexis
mais après c'est vrai qu'ils ont une
super star comme Fabiano Carona alors
est-ce qu'il va réussir à compenser un
petit peu la faiblesse de leur échiquier
féminin et un peu la question de ce
de ce match on va voir si fabianokawana
va réussir à compenser tout ça
alors on a tu vois que la caméra ça
bouge pas moi qui bouge pas et j'ai pas
les caméras blanches en fait il y a une
équipe donc les prochaines bulldogues
j'ai pas de caméra encore là le lien
youtube il est mort
et
l'autre la caméra elle est buggée et
elle bouge pas je comprends je comprends
ces trucs je suis tellement intergalaire
ça c'est extraordinaire c'est les
vacances non mais en fait moi je m'en
fous enfin je fais piquer bien enfin je
fais bien un truc tu vois mais ça marche
c'est très compliqué on va le dire aux
gens c'est pas du tout moi là qui qui
fait le problème bonjour
il y a pas de caméra de toute façon ça
marche pas mais dès que
au moins j'ai le problème enfin au moins
dès que j'aurai le caméra mais c'est
vraiment de vous mettre
mais là j'ai rien voilà donc on va voir
ouais on a une petite finale entre BOC
et le jeune joueur indien il est mal au
temps il a des petits problèmes à
résoudre il y a le pion c'est 7 sous
pression est-ce qu'on fait grand rock
grand qui a fougé 5 tu es dans le
clouage ok G5 peut-être 5 peut-être
encore mieux
peut-être parce que sur Fougères je
pensais qu'il y avait il y avait il y
avait peut-être montré grand rock où
j'ai 5 fous prends des 5 et bon c'est
toujours ah non ah oui non papa paquet
j'ai 5 oui euh non sur ouais ça ça va
pas de problème
je pense c'est que j'ai cinq idées et on
menace
on menace de de prendre un aussi c'est
de détériorer la structure donc vous qui
a des problèmes très concrets à résoudre
il s'est fait un peu attraper dans
l'ouverture
j'ai l'impression
F7 avec moi c'est la différence
il avait été plutôt impressionnant donc
franchement cette partie là bon si on va
dire que si pour moi c'est pas si
incroyable je trouve mais c'est très
très mauvais signe pour les pour
Saint-Louis parce que comme tu l'as dit
il y a Alicia qui est quand même très
très en dessous quoi que à la 2360 alors
peut-être je sais pas
elle est pas elle est en dessous mais
pas pas non plus je suis valova
attention elle peut tout perdre aussi
parce qu'avec son style ça peut
ça passe ou ça casse c'est toujours le
toujours le même problème j'ai 5 je
glisse sépare notre ami ok j'ai 5 était
quand même un coup vraiment envisagé il
décide de mettre une grosse pression sur
sur le joueur alors je sais pas il a un
drapeau irlandais d'origine donc on le
connaît très bien mais c'est vrai que ça
fait un petit moment qui les yeux aux
USA maintenant
je crois qu'il était parti étudier mais
il a pas voulu vraiment revenir mais
c'est comme ça que ça se
c'est comme Jack ça se fait aussi c'est
c'est la magie de la vie parfois on
pense qu'on parle on part dans un voyage
et on va revenir et pareil parfois on
regarde pas donc voilà
c'est là on va être a priori obligé de
prendre et de jouer au roi et fit mais
ça a l'air d'aller en fait et je vais
jouer 7 ensuite je sais pas ce que tu en
penses
tu fais quoi c'est quoi le problème
si je fais cavaler des 7
pour
je suis obligé de prendre
je vais prendre plutôt non je vais
prendre je vais ranger 7 et de faire
tourner 8 rapidement mais c'est vrai que
les Blancs restent quand même avec une
pression désagréable
complètement accordé ok on va voir ce
qu'il va faire mais à part c'est quoi
son option sur F6
je la vois pas je crois que c'est la
position de la partie est-ce que je peux
pas passer
avant de faire
[Musique]
ah oui c'est ça ah mais non
le plus bête du monde
en fait
c'est la partie c'est la partie 4 ok il
veut faire F5 clairement avec les noix
il veut jouer F5 pour jouer contre ce
footclasse blanche qui pourrait rayonner
et c'est vrai que si on fait F5 c'est
plus ou moins la seule chance de
l'empêcher de rayonner
donc des Croates
comme ça c'est la première partie bon
c'est
ça c'est un petit peu en place peut-être
comme comme je vous l'ai dit on fait des
on fait des progrès donc les gens se
posent des questions ils savent très
bien que c'est pas idéal que ça marche
comme ça peut-être pour les play-offs ça
sera ça sera mieux fait certainement
même
parce que
j'ai eu les caméras
à 25 26 alors que le match
[Musique]
enfin ouais mais c'est vrai que les
joueurs le problème c'est que les
joueurs arrivent au dernier moment aussi
donc ça c'est
en fait ce que même le lien je l'ai je
l'avais pas tué
le problème des joueurs d'échec
[Musique]
on peut faire à peu près tout ce qu'on a
envie ici les les Blancs ont cette pièce
vous voyez ce cavalier au bord qui est
pas près de rejouer à priori même si ils
vend F4 il est il a pas trop de il a pas
trop de cases après le fou de quatre
blanches qui est complètement en muré
par les pions et vous voyez ce pion
c'est qui qui est très faible peut-être
cavalier à 4 voilà
donc n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre à
nous lâcher un petit pouce à s'abonner à
la chaîne comme ça vous rater rien et
voilà et ça nous aide en plus donc c'est
c'est quand même pas mal car il y a
quatre jouets par Bogdan derech mais la
qualité 5 je suppose ou J5 je saurais
pas quoi jouer tellement la position est
bonne qu'est-ce que tu jouerais toi
Stéphane ici oh là là instinct aussi est
bon
pour les Noirs si tu veux on peut
changer il y a trop de coups il y a trop
de coups et attention il faut pas se
mettre attention si vous avez trop de
bons coups ne réfléchissez pas des
heures pour mettre en anecdote c'est le
seul moyen de la perdre
allez on va regarder la dernière partie
peut-être qu'on a pas vu entre théodoro
qui a fait une qui est un joueur grec
que j'ai j'ai remarqué alors déjà il a
il a plus de 3000 sur
Church Escom et il a fait une médaille
d'or aux Olympiques sur son échec alors
attention c'est quand même un client
très très sérieux je crois qu'il y a les
chic et 3
donc client très sérieux contre une chic
le grand maître le plus grand au monde
qui a mis 2-0 à Maxime va chez Lagrave
qu'on aille simplement qui était était
assez incroyable parce que même quand
Maxime est en léger tilt comme ça il
faut quand même lui mettre les bulles
c'est pas tout parce qu'il a l'air
Antide comme ça ça a l'air facile mais
ça n'est pas du tout hein
il est là quoi
il joue il joue moins bien mais
clairement il faut quand même faut quand
même y aller donc grosse perf on va voir
ce que ça va donner là quand tu es au
deux roues là
pour avoir les apparu et il est encore
bien
il a il a ouvert la la position ouverte
et on voit ce roi qui est quand même
dans les courants G2 il pourrait avoir
un tour des deux échecs qui pour arriver
d'abord un petit B5 le pion B3 qui est
un peu faible on sent qu'il peut se
passer quelque chose pour les Noirs dans
cette position
c'est parfait c'est pas fait
effectivement
pendant que je mets des autres
mais en fait il y avait un bleu il y
avait un bug supplémentaire que j'ai dû
que j'ai dû faire horrible
mais ça va on arrive à gérer et oui sur
je regarde la caméra parce que j'ai pas
j'ai la technique Express mon surnom bon
enfin bon je me suis d'ailleurs auto
et tu surpris dans ce cas-là puisque
c'est Stéphane et en plus j'ai fait
c'est bon stratagème pour pas avoir les
les caméras à gérer
donc voilà ça me fait je suis content
que ça soit Stéphane franchement ça me
fait plaisir parce que c'est vrai que ça
aime beaucoup plus simple de s'asseoir
c'est tout moi ça je m'assois je mets
mes pieds sous la table et j'attends
voilà et regarde des belles parties
d'échec on est content et il est bien
une teach j'aime bien comment il joue
regarde il prend pas de risque pour
l'équipe B5 rela je crois que tu avais
raison je crois que saint Louis là
faut prendre l'eau dans ce match là on
avait déjà parlé de la féminine qui pour
moi c'est une importante enfin c'est
important d'avoir une féminine à 2005 tu
vois parce que ok 23 ça joue mais
dernière échiquier quand même
normalement c'est c'est quand même plus
difficile là à l'Isly bon la crème pas
360 mais bon
elle va jouer contre à 25 30 qui qui est
très très chaud en blé de thérapide elle
va jeter au dos à 2006 et des hack enfin
tu vois c'est quand même extrêmement
difficile et ça joue parce que quand tu
vois devant bah ok
on est plus fort mais bon c'est une
partie c'est du rapide c'est ça quoi et
après c'est équilibré de partout sauf au
dernier il y a quand même 200 points
d'écart
non mais ça dépend si on a un car wanna
à 4 sur 4
je pense que le match est tendu je pense
que si carbona fait 3 c'est mort
dernier match qui a qui a été plutôt
enfin on va pas dire mauvais mais il a
raté pas mal d'occasions pendant un
match je me souviens il avait fait genre
trois
sur 4 ou 2 et demi un truc comme ça et
il aurait dû faire 4 en vrai et enfin vu
des parties il avait perdu des parties
assez incroyables et
et donc mais en tout cas il est capable
de faire un gros résultat aussi un des
Hatch il est il est c'est un jeune un
jeune roumain qui est extrêmement
talentueux et très fort
on vous en parlait ça dépend de sa forme
aussi aujourd'hui mais ça commence très
fort quand même il y a une victoire
rapide contre cheval OVA quoi de mieux
hein en plus pour se mettre en confiance
et après s'habiller avec les Blancs il
est bien préparé ils font ils peuvent il
peut faire ils peuvent faire énormément
oui c'est ça ouais et il peut faire
énormément de points allez raté une
petite combinette pour dire à la fin
de soirée chèque et après je vais
ramasser le plan
et pas c'est pas la combinette la plus
compliquée de famille et tout échec
aussi qui gagnait bon elle a raté que la
tour pouvait bouger ou alors
victoire victoire facile de Fabienne aux
Carola
ouvre le score avec 1-0 du coup donc on
va voir du coup ce qui se passe à côté
regardez je vais vraiment choisir
il y a des chances de que ça fasse nul
et en fait il a noté quand même c'est à
dire qu'il s'est préparé qu'il a bien
noté le style de chevalova et donc il
s'est dit elle va faire quelque chose
elle va jouer actif comme d'habitude et
il a eu bien raison donc qu'est-ce que
ça donne là ça va donner nul on est
d'accord
à ce niveau là tu arrives souvent quand
même à
cibler un peu la faiblesse de
l'adversaire et à jouer dessus tu vois
donc il m'avait dit que je vois c'est
une chose très très tactique donc mon
d'ailleurs on avait adoré son style
enfin j'avais adoré son style pour
répondre à ciel dans le dans le chat
et du coup oui euh
[Musique]
Caravana est capable de jouer tous les
styles aux échecs enfin c'est c'est un
TOP genre quoi et donc du coup ben il a
joué très solide et puis au final il a
réussi aucune chance quoi donc plutôt
cool
qui a très beau style c'est vrai mais
qui arrive pas parfois se contenir
peut-être c'est la ça sera sans objectif
pour arriver à plus de 2500 et déjà
d'une vraiment aussi déjà une très
émergeuse au monde mais voilà pour
passer dans le top 5 peut-être c'est ce
qui lui manque un petit peu on peut pas
toujours toujours jouer actif voilà faut
faire aussi en fonction de des demandes
de la position elle est très jolie cette
position là
parce que là
je m'en sors facilement
et après tu fais kabballer à 5 non
exactement je me venge sur l'autre pion
mais du coup je pensais pas le problème
il faut voir la finale
mais toi aussi ouais alors
et du coup faut calculer ça quoi et bon
bah prise de tête
donc là il y a pas tellement
en même temps non mais en fait elle
est pas content
qui était pas pressé à mon avis ouais
j'ai 6 c'était mieux oui bien sûr je
t'empêche de passer ouais tu m'empêche
de passer donc croiser 6 et là on fait
roi roi quelque part Damdam juste pas
ici
au feeling en Détroit mais bon pour être
proche du pion et en fait
c'était pas bon ah parce que je repasser
pour moi ok
bon on va voir en tout cas c'est la
partie
c'est la partie
il est venu en G6 c'est pas trompé alors
moi je me serais moi je serais tombé en
plein dans le
moi je serai là peut-être ça me paraît
logique pour défendre le pion en fait
mais après c'est vrai qu'il faut
calculer ça
tu sais les trucs que tu reconsidées en
cours de route toujours les longues une
forcées
de de loin et tu dis et en cours de
route tu aurais réfléchi en général tu
trouves ah bah c'est mieux de tout
calculer avant et de pas se tromper on
est d'accord mais pas toujours possible
et c'est jouer d'accord
pas méchamment parce que là je vais te
faire des échecs je vais te prendre à 7
non il y a quand même
D8
et je vais être pour voir si on arrive à
la cathéter et là je pense qu'on arrive
facilement à la casseur il y a aucun
souci
de coller des échecs alors là faut
calculer ça mais ça va gagner enfin pas
sûr ça ça
on peut primo
ou pas
à 4 non à quatre
bon résultat on a envie de dire pour Bob
il était dans les cordes assez vite avec
beaucoup moins de temps mais là il chic
est en train de
bâtir
oh là là le
MVPs j'ai l'impression
et ça va ça risque de faire un deux et
demi et demi pour les Croates
mais en plus il y a des thèmes de maths
[Musique]
objectif des prochains coups en fait ça
aura pas jouer pour mater
si je peux oui
si je peux je prends ça c'est sûr parce
que deux pions
attaqué terminado tourage 7 seul coup
donc
ça c'est depuis en fait
qui va venir attaquer les deux pièces
donc je peux même pas défendre je peux
même pas essayer de manger de ton
justice quoi
donc il
a mangé là
je sais ce qui va tomber là
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
la tour qui défendait ici
j'ai pas de cases pour défendre le pion
échec
et là bon c'est pas encore fini
parce que là du coup bah écoute
[Rires]
incroyable donc ça fait finalement 3 1
pour Saint-Louis qu'on avait un petit
peu ça fait
trois pour Saint-Louis alors que
de sous que c'est ah oui tu passes comme
ça ouais d'accord ok
sinon parce que c'est vrai que c'était
une les noms sur l'autre but est-ce que
tu as les noms des joueurs de sous en
fait non en fait il faut que je fasse
manuellement d'accord
et ça ne marchait pas du coup je passe
par le par l'événement tu sais d'accord
ok ok
alors du coup pour la route
je les ai ici je vais les placer en même
temps ça vous le voyez pas mais donc on
aura du coup dans la ronde 2 karwana qui
va avoir les blancs cette fois-ci
alors attendez Caravana qui va avoir les
blancs
contre
[Musique]
moi
contre Daniel var 2 on va avoir du coup
on va avoir Buck blanc
contre
et je pense qu'il va jouer non il va
jouer
dans le chat
[Musique]
P Alice Lee à 13 ans donc
c'est vrai que
c'est quand même c'est 2360 certes mais
c'est aussi 13 ans donc on imagine que
la pente est plutôt ascendante et
qu'elle va pas avoir 2360 très longtemps
et donc c'est une excellente
une excellente recrue très clairement
il avait il avait les noirs
je te remercie Jacques lagard et c'est
ici les gens qui ont décidé de m'embêter
dans le chat aujourd'hui quelle
information quand il raconte comme ces
variantes mais je te remercie
mais c'est vrai oui ben j'étais j'en
étais convaincu pour pour la nationalité
de
de je sais pas son nom je vais pas dire
son nom parce que je me trompais encore
à ce côté de moi
et puis ouais donc
voilà autant pour moi il fait partie de
la nouvelle génération
d'iranien qui est extrêmement
prometteuse avec tabataba
j'ai vu un message c'est vrai qu'on l'a
vu à la télé avec cette
dentique récemment
je trouve critiqué la
très bien et ce que j'ai trouvé très
bien aussi j'étais pas si tu l'as vu
c'était c'est le docu
que vous pouvez voir sur en replay sur
mycanal du chess boxing très très sympa
ce document
ah ouais très bien très bien
vraiment très beau docu sur le
chasboxing
qui est est-ce que tu as déjà vu en live
du chaos boxing ou pas en live j'avais
j'avais vu des vidéos des vidéos
pour le foot tu vois c'est pas pareil
à Paris
[Musique]
c'était
à la Villette ça va me revenir you shine
moi s'il te plaît si tu te souviens le
chat oh mince au Cabaret Sauvage
c'était long à venir Cabaret Sauvage
très très sympa et l'ambiance est assez
extraordinaire et il est de sport se
font
elles sont assez complémentaires
finalement c'est vrai que c'est un peu
la même chose à part que ouais au lieu
de se mettre des des coups d'échec il y
a des il y a des coups de poing mais
effectivement la stratégie est là tu
vois tu sens que quand même tu es tout
seul dans le sur le ring tu vois tu
portes tous les coachs du monde à la fin
tu es quand même tout seul faut quand
même décider d'une stratégie donc il y a
quand même beaucoup beaucoup de points
communs entre la boxe et les échecs
d'ailleurs généralement
il vaut mieux être plutôt bon boxeur ou
bon aux échecs bon aux échecs parce que
tu commences par les échecs
donc après
entendant nous Stéphane il faut pas être
trop mauvais à la boxe
non mais c'est quand même dangereux en
fait
je me dis que aux échec tu peux enfin si
il y a vraiment une différence de niveau
tu peux gagner comme assez vite
et ou même un jour qui est pas très très
bon même si il pourrait jouer le Time
peut-être mais en fait il y a un arbitre
et les parties sont très rapides et
Thomas Cazeneuve que tu dois connaître
qui est champion du monde qui a il a
gagné une sortie de champion du monde
sans boxer il est il l'a maté au premier
1er round d'échec et c'est combien de
parce que c'est quoi les c'est pas
est-ce que tu as un petit peu les règles
il y a des formats alors là je sais que
le championnat du monde c'était 4
minutes 4 minutes chacun donc c'est
parti archi rapide avec des des rampes
de boxe donc tu vois il devait jouer
deux minutes aux échecs et ensuite il y
avait un rampe de boxe de 3 minutes ou
de deux minutes comme quoi tu as pas le
droit de réfléchir trop
longtemps il y a une règle ou réfléchir
trop longtemps sur un coup mais c'est
vrai que ouais au Cabaret Sauvage
c'était quand même un truc plus c'était
du 5 5 ou 6 6 je crois avec des rampes
de boxe de 3 minutes et il y avait une
arbitre une arbitre qui est qui est
d'ailleurs connue dans le milieu des
échec c'est une armée d'échec c'est
anémone que je dirais qui arbitrait
voilà qui qui veillait à ce qui est pas
de d'antiger
de la part des des boxeurs c'est vrai
que tu étais tenté d'attendre c'était
maths en trois
effectivement tu pourrais jouer la
montre et je voulais rendre de boxe mais
ça c'est complètement interdit
[Rires]
IVe
aux échecs a priori t'as pas trop trop
de chance ouais mais quand même tu vois
après c'est un petit peu sonné tu peux
donner des pièces quoi mais parce que
j'imagine que c'est pas évident t'as pas
toute ta tête en fait
j'ai été 2016
et Thomas Cazeneuve est assez
impressionnant aux échecs parce qu'il
fait beaucoup de Bullet et tout ça donc
il joue les il joue très très vite et
pas mal du tout il s'est beaucoup
entraîneur Bullet on le sent ça sent
dans ses dans ces parties de chaise
boxing c'est il a il a accumulé beaucoup
beaucoup de réflexes
online ça c'est clair oui c'est
énormément entraîné moi j'attends mon
match que moi je je j'accepte le défi
simplement Annie gay et cyaniche nous
regarde et c'est le seul contre qui je
veux bien jouer au chasse foxing il se
prépare à Nice guéri pour jouer voilà il
y a que je suis prêt à défier le reste
je refuse en vrai ça peut être marrant
en vrai ça peut être marrant ça peut
être marrant moi je trouve ça marrant si
je gagne toujours pareil
mais c'est vrai que toi d'ailleurs de la
box j'en ai jamais fait moi et du coup
je
risque d'être tracé assez drôle à voir
mais c'est l'entraînement c'est comme
tout mais c'est vrai que ouais
évident moi en tout cas c'est c'est
marrant ouais et c'est vrai que que
un petit coup de projecteur enfin un
petit coup tu vois docu sur les échecs
alors évidemment il y a de la boxe mais
docu sur les échecs sur Canal+ enfin
c'est pas c'est pas tous les jours non
plus donc c'est avec des joueurs d'échec
comme Thomas Cazeneuve Lara Armas avec
avec des joueurs d'échecs qui sont en
plus de 2000 il y a aussi
Tony Tony qui doit avoir de dominer
l'eau de Belfort voilà donc il y a quand
même des très bons joueurs parce que
j'avais vu en fait j'avais vu un article
tu vois de cheescom qui parlait aussi de
le dharma champion du monde donc j'avais
lu l'article et du coup j'avais vu des
vidéos j'avais vu des combats donc
j'avais vu dans des gammes et je la
connaissais pas et j'avais vu celui de
la narnasse et j'avais rapidement et
mais c'est tout ce que j'ai vu ouais
mais d'ailleurs elle avait gagné aux
échecs
a fait aussi un
combat comme ça Lauren strent a fait un
combat contre contre notre ami des
chaises bras qui joueront après quand on
cheesebra qui jouera ensuite contre
blistry voilà il y a il y a quand même
il est grand maître d'ailleurs en Bolton
leur instinct et demi donc ça commence à
voilà bon c'est une foutu c'est un truc
de pour diversifier un petit peu
pourquoi pas c'est toujours toujours
positif moi j'ai vu ça une fois ça m'a
la soirée était très sympa donc
je suis allé au Club de Cannes avant toi
voilà
la première fois que tu as mis les pieds
au Club de Cannes
ou 7 ans donc cette année on va pas être
tu es loin derrière ok tu vois derrière
pour la question mais du coup juste je
sais que il y a bon qui a deux étages
qui sont réservés au club mais le
premier étage enfin le rez-de-chaussée
et ben c'est un club de boxe
ah d'accord ok
plein de fois je pensais j'ai dit mais
en fait on pourrait faire un truc quoi
sans blague hein attends même de boxe
surtout qu'il y a des il y a des gens
qui vous devez sympathiser au bout d'un
moment oui très très loin vous
connaissez ouais
du coup parce que j'ai tout préparé
quand même pour vous
une caméra arrive on a Fabi qui joue
contre Dan et cheval donc le jeune
joueur iranien et c'est une position
donc c'est une sorte d'alepine
tout à fait pas un truc 2000 il dit que
va voir le combat de de la sœur de
Andrea bocaisse tu as tu vas être
surpris car tout sympa toute gentil
comme ça et puis sur un ring c'est
quelque chose moi je je
veux pas me battre je veux pas en vrai
non en fait ça ne m'intéresse pas
elle s'y connaît elle s'y connaît non
mais en fait tu sens quelqu'un qui
s'entraîne tu vois c'est pas quelqu'un
qui a commencé avant-hier tu vois c'est
assez assez surprenant
elle perd quand même parce qu'elle perd
aux échecs mais
en boxe
c'est chaud je pense que alors je pense
que tu peux un petit peu malgré tous les
coups tu peux résister après aux échecs
résister parce que enfin c'était moins
fort ça se voit quoi
je pense qu'un meilleur jour d'échec
normalement en moyenne il n'est plus de
match
oui c'est ça
il a très longtemps il était bulgare il
avait 3200 boulettes
et c'était que vous le voyez bon en
photo c'était une masse mais un truc de
fou et lui en fait il était champion du
monde de chaise boxing à l'époque
mais c'était il y a très très longtemps
surtout la boxe mais même aux échecs
quoi
donc c'était un genre qui jouait très
bien très vite et qui en box c'était
déjà très très bon donc là du coup c'est
c'était très chaud mais du coup là je
sais pas si je sais plus comment
s'appelait Tiger quelque chose je sais
plus
je sais pas ça me dit quelque chose
ton histoire
il est normal j'ai pas touché
il doit marcher normalement
la joie même j'ai mon micro tout ça
les écouteurs branchés
ma foi j'aime bien les Noirs dans cette
position c'est tout à fait c'est
intéressant ce qu'il a fait notre ami
Daniel var
et un petit G6 est-ce que moi tant mieux
là excusez-moi je pourquoi je sais pas
pourquoi j'ai un j'ai un autre truc qui
s'est allumé les mystères d'obs des fois
j'ai une piste sur le mélangeur audio
qui s'est qui s'est rajouté
et
j'avais mon mon micro-ox et j'avais un
audio input c'est la même chose en fait
du coup si je dois en même temps ça fait
écho ok ok désolé merci
alors du coup cavaler les deux
ouais non mais bien j'aime bien les
Noirs moi j'aime bien
je sais pas j'ai l'impression qu'on est
venu quand même pour aller jusqu'à Noël
j'aurais fait puis on prend puis on
prend les F4 c'est ce que j'allais dire
tu comprends et qui je voyais pas trop
ce que tu faisais parce que tu as envie
de t'en débarrasser de ce cavalier mais
si tu t'en débarrasses ton pur en D4
devient quand même très faible
donc
je sais pas ça me semblait être le coup
bon apparemment l'ordi elle pas du tout
cavalier F4
ou C2
peut-être à un moment sain quoi c'est
possible est-ce qu'on peut considérer
non non j'ai failli une grosse bêtise
excuse-moi je retire ce que j'ai failli
dire tu as envie de faire [__] non non
mais en fait si tu veux je suis pas
habitué tu es encore un pion en recettes
et du coup j'aurais voulu jauger 5
c'est défendu et que je vais faire G4
derrière et ouais mais
tu pointes du doigt un vrai problème
pour les Noirs comment on continue ici
il y a une vraie décision à prendre
moi tu sais quoi me semble pas
complètement ridicule
j'attaque toujours H3 ça me semble hyper
chaud avec les blancs au moins en
pratique et en blitz
tout ça bon il veut manger des cadres
c'est un goût plutôt rouge hein
tu as mal placé tes pièces et tu as pas
l'air de manger hein
et c'est la partie qui est B3 à 5 a été
joué mais à 4 je suppose maintenant et
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
au final la position est très très
bizarre si la page 5 c'est bien dommage
un peu ce qui se passe on voit les les
Saint-Louis qui sont obligés de gagner
pendant les les Bulldogs qui sont
obligés de marquer des points ici dans
cette partie vu que son camion est trop
un ah bah ouais c'est la cata grosse
surprise encore de Alice lit donc ça
donc tout rage 3 ça c'est original
l'idée de Bock
alors c'était quoi comme ouverture
[Musique]
il est quand même dans les tuyaux de
cette semi-tarache
3 et Tac
c'est quand même
et que ma systématique maintenant
bizarrement ça peut paraître étrange
mais ouais c'est quand même des
tentatives de prise d'avantage ou au
moins déstabiliser les blancs c'est un
peu bizarre
il faut défendre le pion mais est-ce que
du coup faut les trois c'était pas bien
où est-ce qu'il faut jouer autre chose
parce que là faut deux c'est la bizarre
quand même et après j'ai un problème
quand même là je risque de perdre
un pion jaune
tout simplement je mange d'une pièce
donc je suis pas sûr
oui c'est pas évident ce que j'ai gagné
quand même avec les Blancs
peut-être c'est ça
taxe De Bock mais c'est hyper compliqué
c'est archi compliqué peut-être qu'il
prend des quatre et la solution
finalement parce que ce cavalière c'est
6 va être en l'air donc il prend des
quatre ouais mais là je joue un coup je
sais pas un coup de fou F6 ou un coup de
j'en sais rien
ça a l'air quand même confort si je me
fais pas mater tu es quand même très
très mal avec les Blancs
après si j'ai pas grand chose la tour
elle est mal placée sur le long terme
mais bon je peux toujours revenir en
Détroit j'ai plein de mais j'avoue que
j'aime bien les Noirs là
[Musique]
on va voir donc mauvaise nouvelle pour
pour Saint-Louis bonne nouvelle pour
nous parce que ça nous fait un match
plus tendu on va voir
qui qui a tout moment peut sortir sa
créativité donc du coup une partie qui
peut devenir très très fort là je pense
tout à fait alors clairement
la caméra
on est parti on a du coup DH blanc qui
vient de perdre entre Alice lie qui veut
se refaire qui joue contre théodoru donc
là c'est une Sicilienne un peu standard
on a la cavaler en dessin
ok
c'est pas terminé mais c'est mieux que
c'est mieux qu'avant la bonne voie là
on considère alors c'est toujours
compliqué en considère plus ou moins que
les noirs sont OK dans un genre de truc
mais quand tu as pas réussi à faire F5
avant le contre-jour c'est quand même
toujours un petit peu désagréable et là
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur cahier prend 3
et quand même très embêtant
et final sont quand même très très
mauvaises pour les noirs on rétrogé de
faire tourner
quand même très moche
il y a toujours
l'air aussi
pour Théodore
du coup
ouais
c'est compliqué là
qui ont fait une mauvaise partie à la
première c'est super
et on a Alicia contre une chiche alors
ça ça sera une vraie surprise parce
qu'une il est chaud il est solide dans
la compétition quand même
ici
G5
[Musique]
j'ai une attaque qui qui est pas mal
aucun complexe en tout cas ça c'est bien
beau avoir
après à 13 ans
pas mal quand même et je pense que
[Musique]
tu vois en fait tu peux stresser de ouf
quand tu joues un genre très très fort
tu vois mais quand tu es tout jeune
comme ça je pense pas que ce soit
enfin je pense tu as pas de limite en
fait
ouais c'est pour si le caractère mais là
oui
on va faire ici pour
encore créer surprise ça serait énorme
complètement compliqué parce que comment
on fait si on veut jouer passif et des
formes de pions je vois pas trop comment
on fait
par exemple et ouais c'est ça et ensuite
je vais t'encaisser le pur donc il faut
absolument créer du contrôle je sais pas
par quel moyen exactement peut-être déjà
puis on prend les trois pions projet 3
et après faire en sorte qu'il se passe
quelque chose
c'est un peu moins grave parce que du
coup j'ai le pion il est un peu faible
quand même mais c'est vrai que si après
je perds je perds aussi ça a l'air dur
quand même
pas du tout
ok pourquoi à cause d'eux non j'allais
dire fois 4 mais il Adam prend 5
qui traîne mais il y a quand même un
problème sur F2 qui peut arriver ça a
l'air ça a l'air pas facile
[Musique]
et de déstabiliser ce fou ce fou F5 taxi
le coin F5 saute et qui essaie deux
peut-être après j'ai G4 en plus ça
dépend tu vois mais regarde tu vas être
obligé de quitter la quatrième je vais
faire
j'ai quatre tu reviens du coup tu as
protégé ton pion eux je reviens avec mon
pion là enfin je défends ici mais après
c'est pas j'ai quand même du cavalier 3
et de tout reprendre ici c'est fou des
cinq tu vois
ou même plus simplement tu sais qui a
essayé d'amener cette fois 4 et on sent
cet échange aussi se fout de casse
blanche
tu as le droit après tu as le pion aussi
c'est tu as le droit qui est très faible
donc ça me ferait très peur ce genre de
choses j'ai cinq été parfois c'est pas
mal de pas être trop en confiance quand
même mais là
ça menace quand même le petit coup G4 je
passe au hasard c'est joli coup et en
fait c'est lui qui reprend aussi ce qui
traîne parce que maintenant j'ai foutu à
5 c'est dimanche il y a un clouage
en fait oui la position des Noirs
visuellement elle a l'air pas mal parce
qu'on a le réactif mais au final et un
grand problème sur le 6 et si on arrive
vraiment à faire ça la position qui peut
s'écrouler complètement en fait
d'accord
après oui il faut 4 aussi voilà c'est
les idées tu vas échanger les fous de 15
secondes parce qu'il y a plein de trous
sur casse blanche l'adversaire et
l'utiliser pour pour attaquer c'est vrai
que sur le long terme en fait
si les Noirs arrivent pas concrétiser
quelque chose rapidement ben il voit
très très mal quoi parce qu'il y a des
coups trop de problèmes sur quasiment je
crois
intéressant en tout cas cette position
ouais il va trouver
ça c'est clair parce qu'après il y a pas
d'autres il y a pas grand chose à faire
en fait sinon
en fait t'es pas très bien avec les
Blancs ça passe ce truc concret non tu
peux pas jouer
donc absolument rien
[Musique]
à la limite tu auras 7 pour essayer de
déstabiliser mais bon imite ça attaque
le fou on défend et puis voilà on entend
bien
et je récupère
je récupère mon du et je suis pas mal
j'ai l'impression il a peur de fou comme
ça au final
au minimum peut-être il y a plus hein on
peut même jouer 7 et dire bon bah
débrouille-toi mais juste pour montrer à
quel point c'est ok là je vois ça bien
sûr de mettre le fond en G4 et pas en G6
parce que là et bah fait coucou je
reviens ici et tu as donné la tour pour
prendre la dame que si je viens en G4 et
bah tu peux pas faire de la froid et
échec a découvert que je prends je
prends la dans mon prochain coup
il a pas du tout
c'est assez incroyable ce qui se passe
alors attends c'était quoi l'idée déjà
de trouver cette
mal à comprendre
je sais pas c'est quoi ça
intermédiaire
tout en protégeant 5 et effectivement
l'idée positionnelle est réalisée ok
mais du coup elle elle avait déjà vu et
là je fous je capte tempo ouais c'est ça
c'est pas possible du coup
et cavale et F3 et maintenant avoir un
peu ce qui se passe il y a la dame elle
a emprise quand même il faut le dire
parce que je suis cloué mais bon qui
reviendra manger le fou donc là j'ai
quand même ça enfin maintenant en prise
tu attaques le cavalier s'attaque la
tour
je sais pas je suis un peu OK
mais bon ça a été dans le couloir et
tout ça c'est pas très agréable
je comprends très vite il faut prendre
un F3 il faut prendre le 6
il s'appelle il s'appelle
mental combat
donc allez voir si vous voulez alors
faut prendre aussi
ça s'est joué
et là du coup
je pense qu'elle a dû rater ça elle
s'est dit peut-être dame bouge et par
exemple sur ça il y a d'un point là il
attaque bon j'arrête pas là mais j'ai un
peu de jeu mais bon c'est pas suffisant
même la tour 1 c'est pas suffisant je
peux même pas ramener ici à cause du Fou
je pense un de ces trois c'est le coup
qu'il a mis dedans clairement ça me
décatour des deux
et
fini
l’avantage c'est sûr
et plus
ok alors est-ce qu'on revient un petit
peu voir ce qui se passe chez première
table on a Caravana du coup qui joue
contre danesh war dans kerwana blanc et
ça a l'air d'être au final tu vois
positionnellement une masterclass
la différence entre les pièces blanches
et noir
et ouais en fait le cavalier 6 qui l'a
mis dedans
le retour du cavalier qui en fait les
pièces étaient mal placées ça allait pas
du tout
erreur ça pendule 6 secondes contre
quasiment 3 minutes pour sa vie
en fait on a le spoiler on a le scolaire
on va découvrir comment
gagner ok c'est cette chanson terminé
abandon de daniège bar et ça fait ça
commence à faire une grosse Coran pour
Saint-Louis
une réaction rapide des des crash and
Bulldogs donc ici trois quatre qui a un
pion de plus pour les Noirs non même pas
j'ai mal compté
et du coup les plans qui ont réussi
finalement à pas mal s'activer mais le
roi a toujours au centre tu vois que
c'est une partie un petit peu un petit
peu folle où je pense les deux joueurs
ont leur chance ah bah clairement elle
est passionnante cette partie peut tout
se passer il peut tous se passer les
trois résultats sont possibles c'est une
évidence et puis il y aura des erreurs
jusqu'au bout parce que c'est tellement
dur à jouer vous allez proposer
c'est pas si grave au final voilà
il faut quand même trouver du jeu on
tombe il y a ces deux pions qui vont
avancer j'ai ça en l'air
un jeu qui peut être général à base de
fou ces trois mais c'est vrai que cette
tour insaisissent cette femme bon job
défendre et attaquer elle est superbe
cette tour en C6 pour l'instant
à cause de ça comme tu disais est-ce
qu'il y a moyen que je puisse un petit
peu t'attaquer en la bouge enfin en de
la
OK
peut-être B4 son idée logique
c'est de protéger son pion si on perd ce
pion alors c'est pas très grave c'est la
seule pion mais c'est surtout le purin
qui fait qui pourrait faire très très
mal donc tomber cette jouée
pire donc
ça tu lâches à 8e ah non parce qu'en
fait
[Musique]
ton C8 menaces pas parce que c'est
contre par le fou
c'est important attention parce que je
peux avoir des petits réseaux quand même
s'il est fou quand même faut un gros
gros boulot aussi je crois que ça ça va
faire du lait quand même
silencieuse ou si on joue tout reprend
un site pour prendre un 6 il y a plus
rien à espérer que ce soit côté blanc au
côté noir elle joue fous ces trois
cheval je vais fouger 4 échecs
évidemment et elle va gagner un pion ah
c'est bien vu ça elle va gagner un pion
mais ça risque de pas être suffisant je
pense
on pourrait manger à manger là mais avec
les fous comme ça c'est
bloqués pas sûr que ça
potentiellement les noirs peuvent se
créer un pion h passé avec des sacs
qui doit gagner cette partie pour pour
l'équipe
les Bulldogs qui sont Cannes 80 pour
l'instant dans ce match
sa victoire
quand même de inches ça paraissait
quasiment acquis et DH c'était quand
même très bien donc ça pourrait
quasi ça pourrait faire un quatre et
demi trois et demi je sentais comme ça
mais non
[Rires]
il fait attends on va manger encore
attends je vais vous mettre la caméra
c'est incroyable non mais elle a une
réussite elle a 2000% de réussite c'est
incroyable parce que là c'est quand même
c'est quand même ouf de de
en plus hein ce genre de truc tac oh là
là il va leur faire la misère
qui vont faire 100 % aujourd'hui ça va
être très très beau
non mais c'est où être ouf un tour je me
lasse dans la F3 dans mes fins et
tourner un tout à fait qui vient
dévier la dame
je peux donner le fou parce que tu es
large j'adore
si tu prends
la même idée du coup tu as pas gagné
ce résultat je pense va complètement
[Musique]
quelque chose de bien pour les crottes
mais ça va faire un 5 et demi de demi
qui fait cette partie fait très mal au
lieu d'avoir un point d'écart à mis
parcours il y a trois points d'écart
c'est 50 double tout simplement et ça
fait chaud
ah alors peut-être
alors attention
alors oui non mais je comprends que
c'est pas terrible
ok mange comme ça
attention que là donne des pions hein
j'ai chaque roi là
est-ce que ça gagne par exemple quelque
chose comme tour des cinq tours français
4 tu reprends 5 3 points F3 pour éviter
pourquoi pas aller
aussi c'était trois non ça j'aime pas
quand même non non non non non non non
moi j'ai 8 ça a l'air perdu
[Musique]
F et toi
j'aime pas comment
vous l'aurez compris c'est de garder le
pion F3 parce que ça va quand même
simplifier grandement la tâche mais je
crois pas que c'est possible je crois
pas que ce soit
qu'est-ce que tu peux prendre ce pion
dans des conditions acceptables
c'est sûr qu'il fallait pas changer
OK et ça justement c'est ce que j'en
parlais
il y a quelques minutes est-ce que ce
genre de truc ça gagne ou pas moi je
crois pas
et assez facile en fait
donc de contrats aucune charge je crois
enfin après tout ça quand ça va la
défendre évidemment et puis ça c'est
mieux facile
mais ouais
tu vois
et au pire déjà il y a cinq trois après
deux sets avec qui coûte un pont et demi
sur deux enfin au moins au moins un
point sur toi de Alice Lee que nous on
avait plus ou moins essayé de penser en
début de match
parce que tu dis au moins une demi-heure
de là en seconde enfin tu vois il peut
se passer des trucs quand même un petit
F4
est arrivé en fait tu vois ça serait pas
la première fois que quelqu'un perd
cette position avec les
avec les noirs
et ça va faire nul
attention
il joue avec une seconde
4 tu t'es mis dans les envies quand même
on apprend et j'arrive pas à avoir la
position là c'est gagnant pour le
méfier
comme requête avec 5 secondes à la
pendule
on peut montrer le niveau technique moi
un peu le plus beaucoup de temps mais
peut-être que le plus simple peut-être
du B4 en fait
ça sent je voyais pas du tout comment tu
vas
perdu c'est moi qui gagne non aussi
[Musique]
mais ouais mais juste pour montrer ça ça
pourrait être c'est joli mais si tu
prends d'un prends tu gagnes parce que
tu as devient passé mais là ça fait la
promotion dame et là tu n'as plus à mes
F7 et là du coup bon alors
je joue plus pour gagner avec les Noirs
c'est clair
pour faire un peu attention avec ça
voilà oui non B4 était le selon toi
ouais ouais peut-être B4 était mieux je
sais pas est-ce qu'on peut pas aussi moi
je voulais me débarrasser sur eux ah
vas-y attends le BK 3G 4 le roi rg4 ah
oui mais je peux pas faire tourner ça
quoi en fait moi je suis prêt à donner
B5 mais je veux pas donner c'est 5
il y a pas de doute mais c'est pas
complètement trivial quoi encore
réfléchir c'est pas automatique
[Musique]
je prends j'ai quand même
comme ça ça doit être complètement
gagnant
c'est correct on rappelle il y a des
matchs de blitzheim m'a répondu mvl sur
sur Twitter effectivement il se fous de
moi
mais il y avait pas Magnus il y a pas
Magnus tout à fait contrairement à moi
de Paris tu ne vas pas même pas espérer
une seconde que ton prono passe puisque
Magnus ne joue pas bon j'avais
pronostiqué 4 victoires de manuscrit
partout et de victoire de Blitz au bout
du suspense bon bref c'est vraiment
c'est c'est fort c'est fort de de
c'est le panache quoi
bon
bienvenue Maxime si nous regarde salut
amical et bonne chance évidemment à nos
amis de des amis de
Blitz
donc là je vais vous mettre les caméras
on a une qui va jouer du coup contre
carwana
[Musique]
c'est deux des grands favoris de la
Reiki
après on va avoir des
[Musique]
blancs
après on va avoir Théodore
contre
chou valova
hop non
ouais on va voir ce que ça va donner
chevalova qui a fait nul tout le monde
je crois a ouvert son compteur
parce que normalement il y a toujours
quelqu'un qui est en train de prendre le
haut complètement et puis après deux
rondes on voit que tout le monde a
marqué un petit truc alors évidemment
gros avantage pour Saint-Louis
avec ce bien ok pour l'instant
démonstration avec deux sur deux
ça va devenir plus dur maintenant mais
bon on a vu qu'une teach pouvait aussi
acheter des choses donc là j'ai si vous
voulez je vais vous montrer le
scoreboard avec les résultats des
joueurs en direct donc on a du coup dans
l'équipe des Saint-Louis arche big shop
on a du coup carvana qui a deux sur deux
BOC un sur deux théodoro un demi sur
deux et Alice lit avec un et demi sur
deux ça c'est la grande surprise pour
l'instant de cette de cette ronde
Laurent et
chez les croissiad bulldogue on a du
coup donc on va commencer par par
bardilla d'un échelard qui a ici un demi
sur deux je suis valova 1/2 aussi et
ensuite des hack qui a un sur deux
qui a aussi un sur deux avec de nuls
donc bon 5-3 pour l'instant pour les
arts Bishop c'est pas encore terminé un
petit 3 1 renverserait la vapeur donc
donc voilà un petit trois et demi heure
et demi finale match
dans l'autre sens c'est ça donc on va
voir on va voir ce ben non de toute
façon pour les plus savants plus c'est
ici on rappelle c'est un huitième de
finale aujourd'hui entre
Saint-Louis et les Bulldogs le perdant
est éliminé de cette proXess League le
vainqueur est en quart de finale ça sera
la même chose pour l'équipe française de
Blist stream passe au Canadien
holando canavien canadien des chaises
bois avec Annie guerrier aux deux
premiers échiquiers
au match à suivre à partir de 10
8h c'est ça c'est 18h
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est le bleu
on va pas commenter qui qui fait quoi ou
pas
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que les
mesures moi j'ai joué tu vois j'ai sa
première fois que j'ai joué sur un
tournage comme honnêtement moi-même tu
vois en partie il y a quand même il y a
quand même des mesures anti triche qui
sont assez sévères enfin c'est sévère
assez strict disons avec deux caméras
alors je devais me filmer j'avais une
caméra en face de moi une caméra
derrière j'ai dû faire après la rentrée
je peux vous dire en plus je jouais pas
bon bref j'ai dû faire respecter ma
juger j'ai fait un tour mais oui mais je
suis respecté les parties d'abord
et donc j'ai dû j'ai pris mon ordinateur
portable j'ai j'ai fait faire le tour de
la de la pièce
et il a fait ça avec tout le monde moi
je sais on va essayer de colle de mettre
une dizaine dans ce col donc il y a 150
joueurs dans une quinzaine de colle
comme ça où il y avait à chaque fois une
personne qui après sa grande alors
évidemment ils font ça ils font ça bien
et avec politesse et respect mais quand
même il faut faire le tour de la pièce
voilà il y a quand même des contrôles
alors évidemment
les gens sont seuls chez eux évidemment
tu auras comme aux échecs ou ailleurs il
y aura toujours
en tout cas tout est fait pour
l'empêcher et à titre personnel moi je
vois pas de
je vois mais je vois jamais ces trucs là
donc je suis pas une référence voilà moi
j'ai eu quelqu'un qui a longtemps
quelqu'un qui trichait à 2 mètres de moi
pendant 3 semaines par deux semaines aux
Olympiques et je l'ai pas vu donc voilà
moi je vois rien je vois je vois jamais
ces trucs là
et puis après tu
tu vas faire confiance quoi voilà et
penser
de penser ça quoi exactement j'y pense
pas quoi ouais je me dis que c'est
tellement tellement nul que
ça n'arrive pas mais voilà après bon on
voit quand même hein regardez
manuscarsen c'est le Torah du
Championship je vous invite à regarder
les résultats étoiles champions les
résultats des Championnats du Monde
rapides on voit qu'il y a le même
vainqueur donc c'est plutôt quand même
rassurant tout ça
donc voilà je pense pas que je pense que
si le fait que maintenant ça c'est un
problème qui soit quand même pris après
avoir le corps le fait de
pouvoir se faire prendre pour les
joueurs c'est quand même c'est une fin
de carrière ah oui non mais
c'est très très risqué de faire ça donc
moi je sais pas je sais pas peut-être
qu'elle a un ou deux qui risques
qu'elles sont vraiment les tu vois
l'enjeu vraiment parce que si tu te fais
prendre
en fait tu as perdu quoi
bah oui en plus tu vois pour quelques
milliers de dollars tu parles d'un truc
quoi alors que c'est un truc bon j'ai
pas pour les top joueurs on va dire au
top 10 top 20 mondial bah c'est un truc
c'est les échecs c'est quand même
quelque chose c'est impression et c'est
un métier dont ils vont vivre très bien
jusqu'à la fin de leur jours s'ils font
pas trop n'importe quoi voilà donc il y
a pas même s'ils sont profondément
malhonnêtes on peut penser ce qu'on veut
d'un point de vue de raisonnement il
faudrait qu'il soit malhonnête et
stupide pour faire ça
et malin et malin en même temps pour pas
se faire prendre donc bon ça commence à
faire beaucoup donc je crois pas mais
voilà je sais pas non après c'est quand
même bien surveiller ce qui aime bien
tout ça bah oui bah il y a quand même il
y a le même vainqueur à chaque fois en
fait je veux pas là c'est bien quand
même on a quand même les mêmes quand tu
regardes Magnus et Nakamura et bien
champion du monde de Blitz je crois il y
a 2020 ou 2021 c'était 1 et 2 et on sait
très bien que la caméra et le deuxième
meilleur buteur au monde ou le premier
avec Magnus
et au coup d'un coup et on voit que dans
cette tournoi online ils sont quand même
ils sont quand même nettement dessus je
crois que nakamuro il a 11 sur 12 là
pour l'instant en procès League Magnus
il a dit
il a raté un matin deux quand il a perdu
bon autant dire qu'en tout cas
là il y avait pas trop de
pas énormément de doute
mais après tout est possible et je
répète moi en tout cas je vois jamais ce
truc là
je sais pas si c'était
moi je pense
pour une compétition comme ça alors je
dis ça mais je crois que c'était l'année
dernière où il y a 2 ans il y avait une
équipe qui avait triché enfin un joueur
d'une équipe qui avait triché d'ailleurs
[Musique]
qui avait triché et apparemment c'était
flagrant il y a eu plein de choses plein
d'enquêtes et ça a été avéré etc donc il
utilise qualifié l'équipe n'a pas reçu
son argent qu'elle avait gagné je crois
qu'ils ont gagné la compétition un truc
comme ça ouais je me rappelle et
mais bon bah ce jour-là mais il est fini
en fait tu le reverras plus en tout cas
enfin
c'est un joueur qui avait 2006 et
quelques donc déjà c'est un très grand
joueur mais en fait
tu vois dès que tu te fais griller en
fait et ben au niveau des invitations au
niveau de tout ça ben tu n'as plus en
fait
j'ai joué pour énormément et là il y a
le Président je sais plus qui c'est il y
en a tu sais pas si tu as vu mais il y a
norvégien qui a admis avoir triché entre
Chelsea
c'était le le
jour à l'époque où je jouais c'est
vraiment c'est à chaque fois c'est la
meilleure
j'espère que c'est des matchs je me
rappelle même plus si j'ai joué avec lui
ou pas je me rappelle juste que je
quittais le chat assez rapidement parce
que Magnus me demandait des explications
sur mes coups donc c'est pas c'est pas
toi qui qui m'arrangeait mais voilà bon
ben ça arrive
ça arrive c'est comme ça petrociant que
je connais en fait que je connais depuis
très longtemps qui est un très très bon
donc je sais j'avais vu les parties mais
oui bon après il y a des secteurs
anti-riches qui sont quand même très
très bien fait donc c'est c'est ils sont
pas en fait donc c'est ça le c'est ça le
truc aussi c'est qu'il se trompe pas
c'est très bien fait un ne trichez pas
sur sur cheesecom parce que vous allez
vous faire prendre je vous le dire parce
que les trucs anti-rich sont quand même
sont extrêmement bien fait les
algorithmes sont très bien fait
donc voilà bon en tout cas on a un beau
match aujourd'hui avec des beaux joueurs
et vraiment là du tout les retournements
qu'on a aujourd'hui il y a pas trop de
doute
pas trop de doute non non
en tout cas mais puis même je pense que
dans tout ce qu'on a commandé depuis le
début non moi j'ai rien vu j'ai pas vu
j'ai pas vu de quoi que ce soit qui soit
l'armant ou
non et même là que j'ai joué
ça allait partir je suis gagnant je suis
perdant je suis regagnant je le
reperdant
mes adversaires j'avais pas vu un qui
qui était
tu vois où j'ai eu un petit où je ou en
fait c'est même pas
j'appellerai pas ça un soupçon mais tu
vois mais il y a pas un moment où je me
suis posé la question tu vois
c'est les parties étaient complètement
normal quoi
en stream tu te dis
tu as un joueur qui tu veux tu
dis mais c'est trop bizarre tu vois et
l'autre jour j'ai j'ai reçu deux
messages j'espère dans la même journée
qui m'ont rendu des points pour
différents
et au final mais en plus le truc c'est
quand je quand j'étais en string je le
savais parce que quand je
j'ai vu la partie j'ai dit mais c'est
vraiment vraiment trop bizarre et bah
ouais c'est fait et il y en a eu un
autre que j'avais pas soupçonné
c'est Kevin a le droit de penser sur les
inspections
je sais pas après ça dépend aussi de
chacun ce qu'on pense qu'on pense pas
voilà j'en sais rien je sais que ça je
suis pas naïf non plus je sais que ça
existait évidemment mais là sur un truc
comme ça avec les meilleurs joueurs du
monde je crois qu'ils ont trop à perdre
je peux je peux me tromper
trois paires depuis maintenant avec tout
ce qui se passe les histoires de triche
de partout
tu vois c'est pas le moment et bon même
si tu l'avais fait il y a peut-être 4-5
ans je t'aurais dit c'est pas bien mais
bon c'était pas vraiment sous les
projecteurs comme maintenant avec
l'histoire animale etc donc c'est vrai
que bon là en fait je vais rajouter je
vais aller sur dans ton sens parce que
sur Internet c'était considéré comme
différent tu vois de tricher en live
mais c'est je sens que c'est de moins en
moins le cas tu vois que finalement tu
as triché sur Internet ou tu as triché
en live finalement tu as triché quoi moi
ce qui paraît logique alors qu'avant
pêcher sur internet tu vois bon oui bon
il y a triché sur Internet ben c'est pas
si grave et ça c'est en train de changer
évidemment et notamment avec va faire
[Musique]
du mes écouteurs des fois on parle de
l'image
donc voilà parce que dimanche
effectivement bon on va pas y revenir
mais il a admis de lui-même et qu'il
avait triché online et donc après la
confiance est quand même
elle rompue en tout cas en ce qui me
tu vois quand tu es toujours
professionnel enfin toi demain tu
triches tu te fais prendre bah
franchement tu as peur de gros quoi
évidemment évidemment déjà tout ce qui
est Magnus ben il voudra sûrement
travailler avec toi
tu as raison
mais même les
tournois
qui travaille avec bien sûr non mais
bien sûr non mais tu vois ils ont raison
tu vas les faire
tu vois et en fait il y a des gens qui
veulent plus jouer avec toi et des ouais
non mais lui la triche tu fais un
tournoi
ça va pas de sens et voilà je dis toi
comme je dis en fait n'importe où
n'importe qui mais toi comme tu es fort
et reconnu c'est pas pareil que moi par
exemple mais
c'est pareil en fait juste une tricher
partout peu importe l'événement peu
importe Internet par Internet entre
potes enfin juste ne faites pas parce
que vous perdez la confiance en fait
et puis vous vous disiez enfin votre
image enfin tout enfin juste
pas bien quoi
ok vous êtes partis c'est une
Espagnole d'échange avec un un schéma un
peu j'avais dit
rose solimesque
tout à fait on est ouais alors un peu
différent avec ce pion c'est cette
quinceste qui qui fait que qui rend les
grands rock en fait beaucoup plus
faisable parce qu'il est devant le roi
c'est ça et du coup voilà dans ces dans
ces positions de berlinois d'antiberlin
on peut faire grand rock beaucoup plus
facilement et bon la position est fermée
moi j'aime bien les noirs de position
parce que en fait ça ça va assez
confortable on va faire F6 on va faire
roi B8 H5 peut-être
dès qu'on peut on met un cavalier sur
aussi c'est quand même la place du
cavalier bon là on peut pas trop parce
que c'est vrai que les cases de
les cases de de F8 et c'est 5 ou pour
écoulisser le cavalier sans prise pour
l'instant mais
et c'est des cases et c'est intéressant
cette majorité de pions tu vois les
finales de pions qui pour gagner
maintenant elles sont même plus
gagnantes tu as pas pousser des 3D 4
et donc voilà la position est fermée
certes mais ça peut être dangereux on
peut envoyer à 5 à 4 là de truc alors
faut protéger d'abord peut-être d'abord
je sais pas et potentiellement et un peu
d'attaque en plus c'est cavaliers sont
un peu aux fraises allez le roi des
blancs donc
je trouve avec les Noirs en plus c'est
pas dur à jouer j'aime bien les Noirs
[Musique]
dans cette deuxième table bah écoute bah
ça va pour une chic ou pas
donc là je pense que voilà qui veut
mettre le cavalier peut-être en E5 ou
des 4
tours des 5 du coup un peu empêcher
de prendre pas obligé mais bon c'est
recommandé
parce que si jamais j'arrive à faire 500
est-ce que c'est ça peut être un
problème pour toi que je regarde
mon cavalier
j'ai l'impression que je vais égaliser
si je vends des remarque pas sûr parce
que sur Cavalo 5 tu auras tour des 5 et
après je vais mettre une autre tour en
D1 alors je sais pas du coup j'ai pas le
temps de faire comme tu dis à cause de
ça et là maintenant 31 tu pourras plus
mettre le cadet je suis trop de fois
dessus même si c'est pas si clair il y a
toujours à la fin des petits pions
on prend notre temps peut-être ça peut
être pas mal pour les j'avoue que les
blancs sont enfin ils ont un jeu plus
facile à jouer
et les noirs
des cinq avec un tempo sur le cavalier
et où cette position mais si j'arrive à
mettre un Cabello D4 dans les bonnes
conditions ou même des fois je Caval et
B4 je peux égaliser mais ça reste un
petit peu moins
[Musique]
moins sympa je pour pour les Noirs quand
même cette position c'est trop un le fou
contre enfin contrôle un petit peu
domine le cavalier
et tu vois ce petit arche Bishop en C3
et ouais non belle pollution pour pour
injitz moi j'aime bien les blancs ici
alors il nous demande une manœuvre tour
des cinq H5 H3 est bon bravo
c'est
ça alors
en fait non on va expliquer pourquoi
parce que en fait faire tout ça toi tu
as tout à laquelle sur une case centrale
défendue par deux super pions et si un
jour une tour vient manger le tatou et
ben tu pourras avoir un pion passé
donc plutôt manger de bon je suis pas
quelqu'un d'ailleurs les deux pions sur
leur intéressante mais
en mangeant la tour en dessin et ben je
me crée un pion passé protégé par un
autre pion et du coup ce serait vraiment
très dur mettre le la tour en H5 H3 et
G3 ça a fait une menace en un coup
ok mais le jour où je parle à menace par
exemple je mets un cavalent des quatre
je m'invalle en E5 ou je fais F6 où je
fais G6 enfin j'ai plein de coups pour
défendre au final tu as ta tour qui fait
une menace je parlerai la menace et bah
ta tour sera une Activ elle fera plus
rien à part attaquer un pion qui a dit
défendu alors qu'ici tu vois tu mets une
tour en dessin tu vas doubler sur la
colonne des tu vas essayer de gagner la
colonne D enfin il y a quand même rien à
voir mettez plus les pièces vers le
centre truc qu'une pièce pauvre tout en
H3 qui qui se fait c'est punition quoi
c'est
la tour qui tient va piquer quoi tu vois
c'est clairement ça tu décentralises
pour ça pourrait marcher dans les
positions peut-être plus fermée mais là
la position est trop ouverte aussi faut
garder les pièces au centre il a joué F5
il a joué HK torche 3 mais c'était une
position un peu spéciale où il avait mon
travail une position dans laquelle il
pouvait travailler sur le pion G7 mais
là tu as une super tour en marche 3
c'est vraiment dommage enfin je sais pas
quoi en D5 c'est vraiment dommage de la
mettre en marche 3 donc tout à fait
j'espère qu'on a répondu à ta question
vigueur et salut à toi Yume bienvenue à
tous ceux qui qui arrivent sur la chaîne
et alors qu'est-ce que ça donne KBK
ouais c'est je m'attendais à ça
moi mais pourquoi attends
tu vois enfin ouais c'est joli oui c'est
joli mais ça fait un petit peu
passé
tu vois mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
grave ça fait un peu passé alors moi je
moi je je pourrai pas m'empêcher de le
calculer évidemment moi aussi mais c'est
vrai que le premier truc qui me
viendrait c'est je prends et je tourne
derrière et est-ce que tu peux vraiment
te débarrasser de ma tour ça me créer
c'est depuis on passe tu vois un petit
peu gratuit entre guillemets
qui est un coup regarde regarde quelle
couleur il est le pion attends je vais
changer le coup regarde quelle couleur
il est
[Musique]
il a même pas envisagé de prendre ton
idée est peut-être très très bien en
fait si cavaliers
je vais pas te faire une leçon faut
prendre était très très bien et en
partie j'aurais peut-être non mais c'est
vrai que en l'occurrence qui est propre
elle a l'air complètement foutu en fait
si on regarde la deuxième vue peut-être
aussi je vais arriver le four ailleurs
en fait il y a pas de quoi d'ouverts
aussi il y a pas mal de pions en prise
j'ai ça et je vais faire F4 et en fait
tu peux pas bouger quoi mais bon après
moi c'était plutôt à l'instant que j'ai
tourné un j'ai rien calculé c'était bien
et F4 match joué d'après il est en
danger là Fabian c'est ce que je fais
Dame des deux alors on continue dans le
même esprit pour forcer une décision ou
comment ça marche est-ce qu'on peut
faire est-ce que je peux faire ah E6
est-ce que c'est un coup
ouais
je peux pas manger aussi parce qu'il a
tout débute en prise derrière
tout à fait
[Musique]
tu sais
non en fait tourner c'est un thème connu
de qualité pour
[Musique]
les colonnes sont fermées j'ai mal j'ai
mal évalué
j'aime pas donner du matériel qu'est-ce
que je vous dis
très très bonne aussi en fait c'est
peut-être même plus
encore une fois pour moi c'est leur vie
et c'est c'est
en pratique une fois que tu manges B4 et
que tu joues tourner un enfin je vois
pas ce qui peut t'arriver et tu vas le
mettre le pion en F4 tu as une tête
non ça m'a l'air écrasé quand même
écoute il fait il donne plus rien et il
veut reprendre du python en V6
il y a des belles il a une belle
position
en vrai c'est exemplaire se fout et
hyper hyper fort il a pas voulu les
changer contre le cavalier je fais ça ça
et du coup à la fin bah ça se transforme
un peu dans ce que tu as voulu faire
sans donner le fou contre le cavalier
puisqu'il considère que
tu reprends je mange du pion peut-être
il y a un problème peut-être sur G7
me débattre t'en prends je te crois je
te reprends non
parce que c'est pas gênant échec et des
fois tu vois je commence je serai pas
une embellie là ta roi F1 droit je pense
que ça va pas les étroits
et tout va bien défendre en fait ça va
ouais c'est plus illusion ça fait plus
même ça marche pas on va aller dans son
cuites pour faire un billet incroyable
ça pourrait être un vrai retournement ça
mais bon tu reprends ton reprend alors
quand même plus clean non bah c'est la
partie d'ailleurs
c'est la partie
sur ça
au moins ça
c'est pas mal comme
j'ai l'impression que j'ai une bonne
position
dans les gros matchs depuis tout à
l'heure vous avez pas la bonne caméra je
suis désolé et c'est la partie c'est la
partie d'ailleurs j'aurais pu le dire
d'ailleurs
il va y avoir de la F4
après j'ai le temps peut-être aussi
parce que c'est sûr la F4
par Fabi attention
en plus le fou qui va défendre à deux
enfin en fait pour pour le pion le
contrôle qui qui est pas facile à
apprendre
comment continuer à peut-être dame 5 à
taxer 5 voir pas mal
dame 5 OK
à la fin il y a toujours
défendre le pion
fubéca ça a pas l'air d'être un coup de
génie
on peut on peut commencer à regarder les
choses comme ça
je prends G7
ouvrir et essayer de créer un petit
réseau de maths ouais mais attention moi
je te mets un pion à deux quand même
alors je comprends qu'elle foutait trois
mais
quand même ça je trouve ça crée beaucoup
de jeux pour
oui non je suis d'accord
parce que les Noirs justement comme ils
ont mangé la 4 et gigote
je sais pas ce que je fais
[Musique]
j'ai 5 il faut voir
attention contre le jeu
mais oui j'ai deux c'est un coup je
j'aurais ou alors rouage de finir en G3
et prix
ah pardon excuse-moi oui ok pas vu là il
va faire j'ai 6 ouais il va me laver
quand même pas mal ce pion en fait en
plus avec la dame et le fou je veux
vraiment je le garde bien mais après il
y a peut-être je peux aussi avoir mieux
des fois
c'est le premier coup qu'on regarde en
plus alors fais pas si tu vas jouer ou
pas
mais regardez il a poussé son pion à
Fabi il se crée du contre-jour il se
crée des bons scénario
pour le contre-jour de toute façon
dommage 5 a été joué la jauge elle est
pas fan
alors que nous on aimait bien
et chaque croisé
trois une énorme menace hein
en fait même
tu ne peux pas jouer ça peut-être
3G 2
il y a plus d'échec
c'est quand même compliqué
[Musique]
pas encore
le fou va être perdu mais je fais dame
sur échec en fait mais il y a toujours
quelqu'un
de ce pion à deux qui aime qui est enfin
à 3 pour l'instant j'ai une énorme gaffe
énorme gaffe de lui
mettre 7 quel coup il perd le fou et
maintenant il est moins bien il faut
qu'il est imparfait
je prends C3
bonne chance dans mes fuites
un truc comme ça dans des seins
croissait cette
dame dessin quéchec
roi C7 dame F7
pour que tu puisses pas interposer le
cavalier en fait c'est le c'est l'enjeu
du truc ça en fait maintenant je fais ça
et ça ah ouais mais c'est pas facile
je pense que par élimination tu peux le
trouver parce que tout le reste est là
complètement
il a eu quand même un mouvement d'humeur
ah ben regarde là il commence à ses
sourcils et tout ça il a pas l'air il a
pas un fou de joie évidemment
en plus en pratique tu penses que tu as
tu penses que tu as
[Musique]
pas mal joué quoi là il a comme jeu
d'homme dessin
ouais mais il va faire pas élimination
en fait bon en tout cas il fait le bon
coup de là donc c'est le bon signe déjà
pour lui et sur quoi c'est 7 du coup il
va revenir ici et sur roi
peut-être qu'il a il est pas content
parce qu'il sait que tu peux pas gagner
ah bah oui
mais déjà si il fait nul c'est pas si
mal déjà maintenant
on voit que Fabi c'est le roi pour
insister est-ce que roi des six ah le
roi des 6e message
tout à fait non mais c'est nul c'est nul
c'est juste c'est même pas même pas bi
qui adore jouer parfois un peu plus que
de raison là il a vraiment aucune aucune
raison de le faire si il joue hyper quoi
ouais on va voir peut-être une autre
partie parce que tu es passionnante il
faut avouer mais bon
après la
[Musique]
partie qui était du coup
incroyable hyper cool
attention le roi qui va qui va sortir un
peu alors attends regarde apparemment
beaucoup beaucoup de gens mais bon elle
a 10 secondes à la pendule entre deux
minutes oh ça peut tourner en plus ça
peut tourner ça peut même perdre
je pense que
de pions
ça va un peu
la 3 secondes à la pendule elle a
commencé 10 plus de 1 à l'âge avec une
seconde
gaffe d'après la jauge mais bon ok allez
c'est de faire nul là
clairement
elle répète est-ce qu'ils vont faire nul
ouais c'est signé ok allez Alice
peut-être yes alors on va aller voir
Alice
au moins paire de fou pour les Noirs
clouage depuis un mois fini la liste non
là il y aura pas de miracle
clairement je crois que c'est terminé là
il y aura plus
dernière onde et BOC DH qu'est-ce qui se
passe pour que du coup ça peut être
égalité
non ça peut pas être égal
plus
mais non non
mais non on va aller voir après si tu
veux
incroyable
quasiment quasiment 4h30 en fait encore
que là on voit que que
avec les Blancs il y a quand même moyen
de gagner celle-là en plus il y a un
petit pion passé
que le fou a pas beaucoup de cases
il y a peu de temps la pendule
000 nous dit Yoha ah ça a fait nul ils
ont même mis les rois
[Rires]
bizarre
non mais je sais pas ouais peut-être ok
ok
il y a pas grand chose à faire est-ce
que c'est gagnant ou nul ce genre de
truc j'en sais rien à un truc genre
tu pousses l'option
[Musique]
soit en prise
donc il laisse le pion mais à chaque
fois il y a ces 7 le petit setup c'est 4
et c'est le pion
une dernière ronde du coup très
excitante entre les deux équipes là
avec du coup
ça doit gagner mais
professionnellement t'as pas trop le
droit de dire ça j'ai envie de dire
où tu veux tu vas rentrer là-dedans
trois
qui peuvent venir mais bon évidemment
pas pour contre pour ces joueurs là
c'est de la rigolade qui pourrait être
marrant
moi je tenterais fou ces 6
mais
ils mettent Laurent
[Musique]
comment tu fais pour un an tu l'as pas
le temps
U
très fraude B6
allez on pousse
et abandon
donc c'est assez cool on va vérifier on
va vérifier quand même car voilà
un peu
échec échec et je crois un 7 et si je
suis
classe
il a voulu peut-être qu'il pensait pas
que enfin il a abandonné
sur trois derrière quoi
bah du coup c'est perdu je pense non
c'est perdu c'est sûr
voilà il est complètement
il a vu la nul donc il t'a fait Dame des
cinq il a vu hein mais il a il a fini
par changer d'avisé incroyable
en fait c'est le truc vas-y est-ce que
tu veux c'est de la jouer
c'est nul c'est suffisamment mais c'est
intéressant psychologiquement durant
cette pour dire bon est-ce que tu veux
vraiment la nul ou est-ce que tu penses
que tu veux tenter parce qu'au fond de
lui
et objectivement beaucoup parce que tu
donnes pourquoi ton adversaire fasse des
erreurs il faut lui en donner l'occasion
c'est toujours comme ça et donc là c'est
vrai que tu donnais une occasion bon
c'est un peu un peu cheap oui normal
j'aurais joué dans F7 oui les enfants
dans le chat il y a pas de
garantie oui c'est pas le genre de truc
que je fais non effectivement le truc de
enfin moi je me soucie de souvent dans
les parties
c'est en fait quand j'étais gagnant
pendant toute la partie même à la fin
quand c'est nul je refuse tu sais j'ai
un problème psychologique qu'on vient de
partir j'ai perdu
par orgueil c'est
après c'est vrai que parfois moi ça
revient mais pas très souvent on se le
petit break avant de se remettre de nos
émotions avant ce dernier set qui se
rappelle python si c'est mis 5 et demi
ça fait longtemps ça peut se terminer à
23h cette histoire allez on fait un
petit une petite pause et on se revoit
dans quelques instants à tout de suite
et nous sommes de retour avec Laurent du
coup pour ce dernier set
du match du coup je vous rappelle qu'il
y a une qualif au bout au bout de ce
match il faut absolument gagner pour les
deux filles donc pas encore installés
blancs ici contre contre DH donc c'est
les deux leaders de l'équipe ici
alors je vais voir si on a la ronde 4
qui est sorti du coup et toujours pas
les gens sont pas encore totalement
installés mais d'ici quelques instants
on va avoir du coup les les joueurs qui
vont commencer cette partie donc pour
l'instant si c'est demi à 5,5 pour les
Saint-Louis art Bishop qui ont préqué un
petit option dans ce match notamment
avec avec les deux belles surprises que
nous a donné ici à l'Isly dans ce match
rappelle un qui Alice lis c'est la
féminine de l'équipe des arches Bishop
qui a très très en 2280 non pas en 2360
2700 et nul contre injitch 26
50 à peu près donc comme ça un peu moins
peut-être mais mais super super
résultats en tout cas de cette jeune
joueuse prometteuse qui va jouer ici
maintenant
elle mérite parce que c'est ça aussi les
échecs on peut pas toujours être bien
avoir faut savoir se défendre et elle a
montré ça avec avec brio bon là j'étais
trop hâte là contre Daniel va qui a
l'air d'avoir une belle partie
et on va la voir contre le cheval va
être intéressant il y a que des parties
décisives maintenant là c'est dernière
ronde et du coup les on va dire que les
les parties sont beaucoup plus resserrés
on a le numéro 1 contre numéro 1 numéro
2 contre numéro 2 etc donc du coup c'est
vraiment tout est possible et c'est
chaud donc donc là si c'est mis 5 et
demi un point d'avance pour les arts
Bishop donc grosse partie en tout cas
tout envoyer qui s'en sort très bien là
de cette partie qui a 3 sur 3 ça sort
très bien contre une chips il était
quand même largement dans les cordes
mais voilà c'est l'auteur c'est le
moteur de cette équipe de saint Louis on
l'avait dit avant le stream et avec les
blancs dans la dernière bah il va
essayer de mettre un point comme d'hab
clairement il va essayer de la pression
sur le jeune joueur roumain peut-être
une belle partie donc là on a la partie
sous les yeux qui va débuter
dans quelques instants en tout cas les
joueurs qui sont qui sont en place
je sais pas si ça a commencé ou pas
en tout cas chez moi non je vais cette
rafraîchir parce que après
ça devrait pas tarder
mais effectivement sur internet il peut
changer voilà il fait C4 il charge de
temps en temps donc là les joueurs sont
quand même préparés dans cette
compétition
il y a une qualife c'est un c'est une
partie importante pour les joueurs pour
l'équipe
et dans préparation normale donc là tu
regardes ce que je jouais des Hatch et
il a dû vouloir peut-être trouver une
petite idée d'ailleurs sur ça donc il y
a eu des quatre ici alors on peut
retomber dans un garbida accepté avec
puis on prend ces quatre non il décide
de faire assise pour menacer puis on
prend ces quatre au coup suivant mais
justement il y a plus on prend des 5 et
foudet 3 ok qui a un petit on peut pas
parler de sous variante mais c'est
peut-être pas le coup principal G3 et
normalement le coup joué mais des trois
pourquoi pas intéressant
bon clairement il cherche pas à gagner
dans l'ouverture Fabien ça va être trois
pions isolé hein si si les Noirs
décident de jouer fossette les blancs
prennent assez 5 joue B3 fou B2 et ça
reste une position jouable pour les deux
côtés on peut aussi prendre en V4 et
décider de jouer cette structure qui va
être symétrique avec un légère avantage
pour les blancs donc pas trop de risques
de la part de Fabi à Fougères plus
agressif
[Musique]
on va voir si c'est un pion isolé ou pas
après puis on prend des quatre marques
on fait qu'elle prend et ton C8 il
attend ouais le petit petit coup
d'attente il attend pour développer son
foodcas noir il espère évidemment puis
on prend ses cinq et développer en un
coup son foot casse noire en reprenant
c'est ça il demande à Fabi qu'est-ce que
tu as comme coup utile maintenant l'idée
souvent il y a pris dans ces 5 et
maintenant faut prendre ces 5 le fou a
déjà perdu un thème pour maintenant
ressortir ici alors que si je mangeais
directement en C5 et ben il y aurait
tout prend en un coup vous voyez donc je
gagne un temps en fait avec les Noirs
donc
pas mal pour C8 on attend un peu voir ce
qui se passe chez les noirs
est-ce que je peux tenter cavalier 5 ou
pas
[Musique]
non je crois pas
on prend les deux et deux et puis on
prend des quatre je crois qu'il y a ça
va pas donner grand chose a priori
donc
tu penses que je peux manger des quatre
tout va bien tu prends
avec un X 7 et tout va bien pour les
noirs
[Musique]
parce que je voulais aussi rapidement
sans connaître ça paraît bizarre au
minimum suspect
des hatchs
est-ce qu'on fait un petit tour rapide
on attaque la dame et on veut on va
ramasser la tour donc c'est ça la petite
pointe tactique le prochain coup des
Noirs c'est pure français 4 et on va
essayer de ramasser le pur en dessin
c'est pour ça qu'il joue B3 pour
stabiliser et attention la dame contrôle
maintenant la case 1 et donc on menace
de prendre un B4 a priori le seul coup
ça va être cavalier assis ici
mais on est obligé de le faire
j'ai pris quand même B5 donc je peux
faire A4 cette position je sais pas ce
que ça donne honnêtement
je sais pas trop ce que ça donne cette
position
intéressante
le coût principal
on joue du coup sur quasiment
OK
de pas toucher à l'aide
pour que c'est une décision et de faire
tomber deux mètres de fond sur un grand
diagonale peut-être un coup de F4 qui va
venir aussi et de laisser les le
cavaliers raciste notamment
être un petit peu en Pétré là-bas
ok si on continue notre petit tour et
compare du coup sur la troisième partie
entre danijoard et Théodore
ici
il a perdu un pion
est tombé sur un piège
théorique
connu ça connait si on connaît si on a
amateur de stagnante comme moi avec
cavaliers à 6
on va montrer sa faute et en fait dame 7
la menace cachée
d'ailleurs
j'ai dans mes références une partie de
toi
que je trouve vraiment génialissime
c'est une partie que tu avais joué
contre un je crois que c'était un
Allemand ou je sais plus contre
un et faux et fin il y a une vente avec
à 6 à 5 et blanc je vois assis c'est sur
des 5 que tu joues à 5
tu laisses les blancs jouer enfin tu
joues à 4 pour forcer B4 tu m'incavelas
une histoire de cavaler 1 cavalier à
deux dans sa dernière
mais bon c'est la grande partie de
référence que j'ai en tout cas sur cette
image
[Musique]
que je m'en souvienne pas
ouais ouais non ouais ça fait un petit
moment j'ai touche plus ça doit remonter
ouais c'est vrai
pour le coup ça remonte à mon avis mais
j'ai toujours un petit mais de moins en
moins j'ose plus maintenant mais à
l'époque j'en osé au moins au moins une
parent à trois et tu avais fait et tu
avais fait tout reprend F3 et tu avais
ramené une pièce en F4 et damage 4 et tu
l'avais gagné comme ça mais c'était
c'était ouais c'était juste une très
très bonne partie quoi d'accord bon et
je chercherai parce que ça m'intrigue un
petit peu
vraiment
je vais te laisser 2 secondes
j'espère
alors vas-y en quelle année est indienne
je peux te dire qu'elle a un grand
c'est une c'est une c'est une grande
part de préférence
mais il y a toujours quand même des
problèmes avec ce roi qui est faible un
bon centre beau Cayer des 6 et puis on
qui peuvent venir er
peuvent surgir ton peut-être pour
arriver on sait pas
le jeune fraise comme disait Adrien de
but il disait ça Adrien
tu vois mon écran mais je te montre
[Musique]
très très vite pour toi la preuve de
Joyce
tu l'as vu un cavalle en B3 et tu avais
sacrifié
[Musique]
ah ouais ouais incroyable
ça pour le coup
enfin bref voilà
ok mais merci merci de me de me rappeler
des bons souvenirs je m'en souvenais
plus du tout
à l'époque quand tu joues plus de 100
parties par an
on a les mêmes références en tout cas
c'est bien on s'entend bien ouais mais
j'étais pas réveillé en fait à cette
partie c'est pour ça que je m'en
souviens plus et c'est pour ça que j'ai
fait cette partie en fait c'est juste
que j'étais en plein milieu de ma nuit
de sommeil je suis arrivé je me suis
levé j'ai fait j'ai vu un truc à F3 j'ai
pris et voilà et bon bah apparemment
c'est une bonne partie tant mieux
alors il est bien avec les Noirs moi
j'aime bien les Noirs
un peu de rêve
c'est rare que ça se passe comme ça
quand même
il est on vient de voir on vient de voir
sa partie patoche Forever salut à top
people salut à tous et
5 peut-être alors
comment on fait pas mal on a quand même
envie dès que c'est possible on a envie
de le sortir de là tu sais tu le mets à
6 en fait c'est cavalier à 6 en fait le
concept c'est de mettre en cavalier à 6
et après tu cherches toute la partie à
le sortir de la 6 ce qui est pas hyper
vite
contradiction mais bon on est pas à ça
près donc il a mangé à 7
bon c'est alors bizarre mais je
comprends il sait qu'il est moins bien
et il veut essayer de prendre des
risques
donc après comment est-ce qu'on peut
punir et quand même deux fois en prise
ce cavalier donc tu auras 8 ne marche
pas à cause dedans prend ces cinq pour
l'instant moi j'ai envie de faire une
petite tactique là tu vas chauffer avec
mais avec ma partie là de contre l'auber
Caval F5
[Musique]
donc B6 c'est pas mal parce que ça
menace de gagner la dame par tour à 8
donc damma 3 a l'air d'être plus ou
moins forcé est-ce que tu perdrais pas
la dame sur tabacro ah non toi vite de
MBK turagate dame ouais mais au pire je
fais tour à 8 MBK tu reprends à deux
trois quatre d'abord au pire ça
au pire tu as ça
fait pas plaisir du tout très très
mauvaise partie de notre ami Rania pour
la dernière
ils nous prévoit un sacrifice de dames
notre ami 38 il veut encaisser en 8 et
encaisser en C5
bon ma foi pourquoi pas
non parce que tu as repris de la dame en
donc du coup
moi je triche tu triches moins que moi
tu bouges pas
ça m'arrive pas
à la dame elle a bougé tu vois donc du
coup j'ai pas les hallucinations sur la
case de départ retour donc j'ai plus de
5 ouais
effectivement ça semble un peu léger
surtout le roi G2 encore je dis pas mais
sans le purger
ouais alors du coup est-ce qu'on a pas
encore vu la partie des féminines du
coup on est parti là-dessus
changez ça bon Alice Lee elle a les
noirs elle a un pion moins net elle est
foutue mais la partie commence parce que
Alice elle joue ça toujours enfin en
tout cas depuis le début de cette
journée habitué à nous faire des
défenses de feu donc voilà
on a on attend on attend qu'elle donne
il y a des joueurs comme ça
des joueurs qui se passaient tu as dû
remarquer forcément il y a des joueurs
qui jouent beaucoup beaucoup mieux en
fait la partie commence quand il
commence à être mal ils arrivent pas à
se mettre dedans avant et c'est assez
étrange je suis un peu comme ça moi en
fait je suis jamais aussi dangereux que
quand je suis mal d'accord et parce
qu'en fait j'aime pas perdre et je vais
tout faire pour pour et même à l'époque
j'avais enfin mes potes me disait que
j'étais un gros voleur mais en fait je
pense pas qu'il te voleur en fait
enfin dans le sens il y a le mec qui qui
joue pas bien qui fait plein d'arnaque
etc mais en fait
ben ça montre aussi une force de
caractère et une force aussi
il sait que c'est nul mais c'est vrai
que d'un point de vue
optiquement ça a l'air complètement
foutu à chaque fois et il sait que ça
tient et voilà il fait des forces des
trucs et cette partie contre cramique je
crois que c'était la Coupe du monde
d'ailleurs notamment
Maxime il y a des années une forteresse
qu'il avait trouvé un petit monstrueux
mais oui c'est clair quand tu es foutu
en fait tu cherches à toutes les tous
les trucs possibles et imaginables pour
essayer de pas perdre
et voilà bah d'ailleurs j'ai fait une de
mes dernières parties lente j'ai joué un
2000 et j'ai fait une énorme faute de
calcul et je pense enfin je pensais le
matin en fait dans une variante et du
coup au final je me suis complètement
planté je pensais que je devais être mat
et un demi bon ça me fait ça me fait
beaucoup mal tu vois à mon élo tout ça
un 2000 et je réfléchis une demi-heure
jusqu'à trouver un service de dames
positionnel qui en fait était bon il y
avait un coup perdu mais c'était un truc
d'ordinateur qui était absolument
introuvable mais au lieu de ça en fait
et Ben et ben en jouant les coups
normaux bah trois coups après
l'abandonnée
c'est vrai que celui qui
prouve le mieux le meilleur dans ça
tu as raison
bon là par contre elle est quand même
elle est quand même pas terrible parce
que si dès si ça arrive si décide en
bonne condition arrive c'est quand même
poussé un petit peu mon pion juste pour
te dire ok
à faire un coup de C4 un truc comme ça
on va essayer de créer un peu la zizanie
chez l'adversaire on va voir donc ça se
passe bien pour chovalova ça se passe
bien pour théodoru donc ça ça fait ça
fait un partout et ensuite carwana on va
aller voir peut-être 40 et Boch bloque
une chic qu'on a pas vu on les a vu le
booking
enterrer le matin
parce que la finale elle est
complètement gagnante avec ces deux
pions avec ces trois pions passer liés A
et B à la dame on peut juste échanger
les dames d'un prime G2 terminal 2
3 G6 en plus
[Musique]
et ok bon c'est gagnant et du coup la
partie qu'on va voir c'est karwana
ne perd pas c'est déjà terminé en fait
et à regarder 8 secondes pour des ce
match peut être terminé très rapidement
pour les blancs c'est pas simple c'est
très chaud
très très chaud
j'aime bien j'aime en vrai avec la
position à la pendule
je trouve ça très très dur à jouer pour
les pour les noirs avec ces deux pions
passer lié là pas encore pas depuis on
va s'élier mais après ce pion c'est
passé qui menace d'être soutenu par le
cette majorité AB contrat
on a vu que il était quand même alors il
est bon en taille note mais il est quand
même il fait des gaffe la 5 secondes
[Musique]
en pratique on va pas laisser de
l'adversaire on fout des quatre fou ou
deux et peut-être pousser les pions
comme ça
c'est parti
et comment on va faire maintenant
et là du coup
[Musique]
j'aime bien
fait très mal à mon avis
le fou qui pourrait venir bloquer on va
sur la couleur du foie adverse c'est
important donc
[Musique]
il va essayer de se battre quand même
qui est parti
alors qu'il abandonné donc c'est fini et
demi il reste une partie victoire de
Saint-Louis qui se qualifie pour les le
play-off c'est ça et je sais pas si tu
te souviens mais ça Louise avait
commencé avec deux défaites et depuis
ils ont eu que des finales gagné à
chaque fois après
donc la partie la partie qui est qui est
encore là il est joueuses qui jouent le
match est terminé match terminé
Saint-Louis qui se qualifie pour les 8e
du coup donc il y a encore un match
aujourd'hui juste après ça à 18h donc
c'est le match
donc c'est Blitz donc l'équipe de Blitz
stream que vous connaissez tous qui va
affronter du coup
l'équipe des Canada chassebra donc
l'équipe de Carlsen sans Carson
donc ça va quand même être un match très
très chaud avec les Canada
forest ils ont Rodrigue Lemieux c'est
champion du monde junior
canadien qui a 24 60 mais qui est
champion du monde donc bon très grosse
pointure et en quatrième position la
féminine à 2350 Jennifer
du monde mvl aussi en changeant du monde
Katerina Lano qui est peut-être aussi
ancien champion du monde je suis pas sûr
allez ciao elle a été champion
[Musique]
donc mail Boyer qui est qui est émis
mais très très rempli de soeur français
en tout cas donc je pense que qu'il y a
quand même un bel avantage pour Blitz
mais encore une fois une très grosse
équipe en face ça reste sur un match
c'est un match c'est toujours dur à dire
ça va être ça va être chaud et c'est à
suivre et ça va être beau parce que en
face
il y a pas Magnus alors ça c'est quand
même une grosse grosse absence mais bon
qui arrive van forest
voilà ça a quand même ça joue clairement
donc bon on va voir ça dépend de la
l'état de forme de chacun on sait que
Maxime Maxime va chez agrave est
toujours
il est fluctuant sur internet il peut
être très très bon il peut être aussi un
peu plus dans le dur ça dépend de sa
forme aussi ouais
alors c'est à suivre c'est pas suivre
ici qui commente Blitz et suivre sur la
sur la chaîne Blitz stream
l'arche favori attention je crois pas
franchement avec parce que es-tu aussi
instable
Kiri est beaucoup plus stable online que
que
bon on verra évidemment mais ils ont un
vrai avantage sur sur Katia
évidemment après sur Man je connais pas
l'autre mais si tu as dit qu'il a été
champion du monde junior bon
effectivement
il avait fait en plus un champion du
monde assez monstrueux
ça joue toujours même si on voit plus
les joueuses il y a dû avoir un résultat
mais Alice
je crois pas une musique qui vient de
sortir une musique qui vient de sortir
j'ai une musique
honnêtement j'entends pas alors
peut-être que c'est moi mais j'entends
pas
cette musique oui on entend et alors moi
j'entends pas je suis seul peut-être
qu'elle vient de moi c'est quoi comme
musique
je sais même pas ce que c'est comme
elle est chez moi mais c'est un truc de
fou
ça
attends Facebook c'est pas ça
du rnb américain d'après je me
bon
les caméras
c'est pas slack je regarde un peu tous
mes trucs non je comprends pas d'où ça
vient
j'espère qu'en tout cas elle est bien la
musique
j'espère qu'elle est bien que je vous
profitez de cette belle ta musique non
c'est ouais
dans le chat le bon ciel bleu on se
méfie
star en musique
je crois pas que ce soit moi alors ou
alors j'ai fait un truc que je mets
normalement rnb américain c'est pas mon
plus c'est pas mon truc normalement
est-ce que non
en plus mais c'est toujours normal je
crois pas là franchement
c'est bon
Alice Lee elle est en train de perdre
mais ça joue pour du beurre est-ce
qu'elle le sait elle le sait pas on n'en
sait rien mais en tout cas qui est
certain c'est que c'est pas très grave
elle va s'incliner mais ce n'est pas
grave du tout c'est beau ça va être ma
F4 va arriver ouais bon j'ai 4 ans F3
F5 et G6 arrive et peut-être en abandon
de alisti tu auras fait quand même une
très très belle journée qui aura bien
aidé son équipe à remporter ce match et
c'est 9 7 pour saloui crochet à
bouledogs qui devra ils devront retenter
leur chance l'année prochaine
[Musique]
j'ai tout fermé un tous mes autres ils
sont fermés
j'ai des sécu
c'est extraordinaire
franchement je crois pas mais alors
encore d'exploiter
est-ce que ça tu m'as coupé là du stream
ok je viens de le faire
mais là moi j'entends encore
et là il me dit recording
je sais pas
j'ai aucun stream ouvert
je suis pas fou quand même
je sais pas je comprends pas ce qui
s'est passé
un gros bug de ouf
peut-être il est temps de souhaiter
bonne chance à vos amis de blistring
féliciter Saint-Louis
dans mon 14 merci pour cette fabuleuse
technique avec musique et tout ah oui
non
c'était très bien mais mais du coup une
question c'est ça pourrait pas être pas
à cause du comment ça s'appelle le riz
stream là et plusieurs chaînes en même
temps non non parce que ça j'ai fait
plein de fois ça m'est jamais arrivé et
moi tout est filmé donc c'est pas
possible là je sais pas franchement
enfin moi j'ai tout coupé chez moi j'ai
rien pour moi j'écoute donc j'ai même
pas franchement j'ai une petite
c'est possible que ça vienne de moi en
fait
non parce que il y a plus mais c'est
bizarre que je t'entende toujours parce
que mes écouteurs ont pu se connecter à
mon téléphone et parfois ça me met de la
musique complètement à random sur mon
téléphone mais je pense pas parce que si
ça c'est si mes appareils Bluetooth
c'était connecté sur mon téléphone ça
serait pas connecté sur le stream
enfin je serais pas je t'entends quoi tu
vois donc c'est un peu bizarre
c'est un peu comme si
ouais peut-être sur le sur le par
rapport au zoom ou quoi mais je suis
même pas vraiment le zoom bah je sais
pas je l'ai pas ouvert en fait moi
j'avais le YouTube j'ai tout fait à Metz
bref peu importe dans tous les cas merci
à tous d'avoir suivi cet événement merci
beaucoup donc là il y a le match qui va
commencer avec Blitz stream du coup et
les
c'était quoi l'équipe le nom de l'équipe
et demain il y a encore un autre match
d'ailleurs mais on sera pas couvert
c'est le match de MGD 1 contre là j'ai
tout fermé à cause de ce bruit mais les
MGD 1 contre une équipe qui était je ne
sais plus quoi et une équipe
malheureusement j'ai tout fermé j'avais
tout ouvert mais j'ai tout fermé parce
que pour écouter
ce que ça venait mais oui je crois je
moque mais genre c'est pas plus GTA tu
as une info quoi tu vois moi j'avais
zéro info
qui va jouer contre je vais vous dire ça
à toute MGD 1 qui va jouer contre les
Garden State passers donc l'équipe de
saviant ça me servir bortnik et cetera
donc voilà encore une fois l'équipe
gagnante se qualifiera pour les
huitièmes donc c'est des matchs très
très important
donc voilà en tout cas merci à tous
d'avoir suivi de stream merci à toi
Laurent pour pour
Stéphane et ben très bientôt du coup
Laurent et à tous sur le sur le stream
et à très bientôt